the documentary filmmaker uses the
camera to show real life and real people
in a way that is insightful often
astonishing but above all truthful this
year's films illuminated the tension and
resentment of those living in the West
Bank
behind the scenes operatives working in
the same working in secret in that same
land the life-and-death battle waged 30
years ago by activists trying to stop
the spread of AIDS the war being waged
against our nation's female warriors and
a journey to find a long-lost musical
legend here are the nominees for Best
Documentary Feature 5 broken cameras
Matt burnout and guide to be the
gatekeepers drawer more Filippo Kowalski
and Estelle feel how to survive a plague
David France and Howard Kirkland the
invisible war Kirby dick and Amy ziering
searching for sugar man Malik
Benja liu and simon shin okay and the
Oscar goes to searching for sugar man
nomination for
oh boy thank you so much thanks today
Academy very very kind thanks to one of
the greatest singers ever Rodriguez and
Steven sugar singing I'm Craig
Bartholomew Camilla sky girl strong SVT
SF I all my friends and family and so
many classics the best distributor on
this planet thank you I also I also want
to thank Sony classics Tom and Michael I
want to thank John bat SEC and rumen and
the team at passion pictures Josh Braun
submarine and my dear wife Laura without
whom any I wouldn't be able to do any of
this
Rodriguez isn't here tonight because he
didn't want to take any of the credit
himself and that just about says
everything about that man and his story
that you want to know thank you